after a 10-month wait open AI have
released Sora to paying users with just
a prompt it can generate videos of up to
20 seconds in lower resolutions and 10
seconds at 1080p if you can Fork out
$200 a month I've tested it and read the
system card the user interface is really
quite beautiful even if the videos
themselves operate under entirely new
rules of physics but I just can't help
wondering if open AI want us to focus on
releases like Sora rather than some
quietly broken promises first things
first Sora is available in almost every
country aside from those of the EU and
the UK and for those of you who've
noticed my acccident you might be
wondering how am I using it and I'm
using a VPN no don't worry I'm not going
to do an awkward segue to a VPN
sponsorship as mentioned at the start
you do need to be a paying user of
Chachi BT to get SORA and the standard
$20 tier only gets ,000 credits and the
meaning of that we'll see in just a
second chat BT plus is also capped at
720p resolution not 1080 and just 5
Seconds of duration pro at $200 a month
gets you 10,000 credits but you also get
to download without the watermark now
you can see how quickly you would use up
those 1,000 credits from the $20 tier
here look 720p 5 Seconds that's 60
credits dare I say it even on the $200
tier you can eat through your credits
quite quickly in fact just prepping for
this video I've probably used up like
80% of my allowance the allowances by
the way don't roll over to the next
month by now I'm sure that almost
everyone watching this video has seen at
least a dozen other videos from other
creators so I'm going to keep this one
short the first is just a standard
generation and it has remembered to pick
out The Shard but I wouldn't say this
Shadow is being cast Over The Shard next
for the budding content creators out
there how about a futuristic YouTube
intro I'm not going to use it for the
channel but I think that's pretty cool
how about the storyboard feature and
honestly I think the user interface is
pretty amazing it's very Apple like very
sleek and clean but of course the
central problem with all sore
Generations indeed all of generative AI
including Chachi BT is that it doesn't
really follow physics it hallucinates so
I prompted Sora with an image I featured
in a previous video and then had the
ending be that the sign falls off the
turtle the turtle doesn't notice and
walks off screen the sign by the way is
supposed to stay on the ground here was
the resulting video now when you're
watching this video remember that if you
buy the $200 tier just for Sora this
video alone used up more than 5% of your
allowance translated it cost you or in
this case me $10 for those listening to
the podcast version of this video the
sign definitively does not fall off the
turtle the next topic that I just have
to get to if any of you are considering
getting sor is the refusals any prompt
mentioning something proprietary in this
case an Arsenal shirt just gets blocked
in this case as with the VPN there is
one way of slightly getting around that
what you can do is generate the relevant
image in a different image generator
something like ideogram or mid Journey
then you feed it in as an image prompt
and lo and behold Sora will generate the
video based on that image notice again
though that this Hedgehog is supposed to
be scoring a goal
rather than just staring at the potato
also did you notice that massive
mangling at the beginning God knows what
that is oh yeah and the potato levitates
so far in my use of image prompts it has
been pretty Hit or Miss I tried to make
the image logo for my AI Insiders on
patreon pop out so I fed in the image
and the prompt as part of a storyboard
and the prompt was the robot and this is
around 4 seconds in it should kick in
the robot holding the AI inside his book
looks at the book then brings it closer
to the screen you can move those prompts
earlier or later in the timeline to
adjust when they kick in the only
problem is as you can see the robot
instantly transforms into a different
robot orbe it holding the right book so
that's really cool but not quite what I
was intending obligatory plug for my $9
a month patreon where I release videos
like this one on the media's
misreporting over 's quote Escape my
favorite creation had to be this one a
hedgehog showing off its vegetables I
did prompt it with an image but I think
the resulting 1080p video is crisp and
clear you might know that your prompt
can be a video not just an image or some
text and so I got Sora to extend this
scene both backwards in time and
forwards in time for cling AI I use the
motion brush tool to get the turtle to
move but Sora quite literally took the
turtle in a different direction
obviously I'm not the best text video
prompter but you can see some hand
selected video
in the featured section on the product
page some of these are pretty incredible
this is 1950 Suburban Bliss generated
just 40 minutes ago 1080p of course this
is a drone shot of a container ship on
docks loading containers not bad at all
if you're just looking for a bit of
cuteness in a quick short video at say
720p there are competitors though like
Runway and paa but yes overall Sora is
the best and especially at higher
resolutions I wouldn't say it's that
close just don't Bank on it being
reliable as Sam Alman found out tonight
when they were doing the live demo in
neither of the videos did the crane
catch a fish then there are Rivals like
Google deepmind who've produced vo their
most capable generative video model the
only problem is it's not accessible to
anyone hardly and definitely not me so
that if you will is my initial review of
Sora the best currently available
although very very pricey with a limited
amount of generations and hardly any
adherence to physics the system card by
the way even though I read it in full
doesn't tell us that much so I've just
picked out five highlights after
covering these highlights I'll touch on
why I think there is an element of
distraction in play first is the team
keeps repeating we made Sora to
understand and simulate the real world a
capability We Believe will be an
important milestone for achieving AGI
here's my cynical theory on that openai
was funded by people like Elon Musk as a
nonprofit to create AGI that benefits
Humanity it is really quite hard to link
the creation of an entertaining video
generator to creating AGI great for
signing up new subscriptions and indeed
new signups are currently blocked
because it's so popular and great of
course for building a ton of Revenue but
really quite hard to link to the
creation of AGI call me cynical but Sora
is miles away from understanding the
real world if could and certainly
further than a model like 01 in chat GPT
just seems like a justification for why
they're doing Sora for all the lawyers
watching they again don't go into where
they get the data from I covered this
back in February of this year they just
say mostly collected from industry
standard machine learning data sets they
are very well aware that they are a big
Target for lawsuits which is why they're
not going to be any more specific one
interesting bit of technical detail is
that they customize their own GPT to
achieve High Precision on the moderation
for certain topics and the reason that
they could afford that latency is
because we're all waiting anyway for the
video generation so they use that window
of time to run this Precision targeted
GPT what that model can do by the way is
identify third-party content as well as
deceptive content I tried clipping out a
section of Lord of the Rings and feeding
it in as a video prompt and it was
flagged immediately next in case you
were wondering or intending to do this
you can't actually ask for a video
generation in the style of a living
artist they thought about allowing this
but then opted for the conservative
approach also you can't use as an image
prompt a photo or video of a real person
they say given the potential for abuse
we are not initially making that
capability available to all users I know
that's not many highlights from a long
report but that is as much as I got and
I think you've got to admit that that
was at least a fairly decent segue to
this video's sponsors 80,000 hours one
of their recent podcasts from the 27th
of November was covering what one critic
calls open AI theft of the Millennium as
you can see they are super highly rated
but they also cover other topics too I'm
also subscribed to their YouTube channel
and tend to listen when I'm doing long
drives or long walks they also produce a
career guide so do check them out with
the links in the description just as I
end though what's that distraction
element that I mentioned at the
beginning for some of you this will be
the most important part of of the video
well we have all of these so-called 12
days of shipus open AI releasing product
after product one after another and all
of us are starting to think about
Christmas and breaks to come so that
would be a good time to bury bad news
just one example would be a coincidence
but three let me know what you think
first on December 2nd open AI opened the
door to doing ads that doesn't sound
like too big of a deal though right
their CFO just said that they're looking
into ads but remember Sam Alman has said
in the past I think that ads plus AI is
sort of uniquely unsettling to me on Lex
Friedman he also called them a last
resort that's just the warm-up though
because on December 6th in the financial
times we got this this story for me if
it turns out to be true is far more
quote unsettling open AI have promised
that when they reach AGI their
commercial contract with Microsoft would
be void all the profits thereafter would
go to their nonprofit to distribute to
everyone that was key because as samman
himself has said AGI would break
capitalism it's even in their very
definition of AGI that it can do half of
the world's jobs they made this
commitment repeatedly I've covered it
many times before on the channel and
it's in their bloody Charter well
apparently they are now discussing
removing that provision AGI according to
this article might well be misused then
for commercial purposes just for a
moment I want you to picture Microsoft
having a monopoly over AGI you might not
believe they would do so and you might
not even believe AGI is coming but just
imagine if those two things happen why
are they trying to ditch this provision
that shuts Microsoft out of its most
advanced models a provision they've
promised repeatedly to uphold well they
are seeking to unlock billions of
dollars of future investment just in
case you think it's me making up all of
these Clauses the Ft directly quotes
them many times according to openai's
own website AGI is explicitly carved out
of all commercial and I P licensing
agreements but there's a problem with
that dear viewer that would limit the
potential profit and value for Microsoft
after all they've pumped in $13 billion
into open AI this would disincentivize
the big Tech group from further
investment oh no by the way this isn't
just rumor this is according to multiple
people familiar with the conversations
mman said apparently we've left
ourselves some flexibility because we
don't know what will happen again though
the Ft quotes from open AI own history
they told anyone investing in them to
consider their investments in the spirit
of a donation with the understanding as
I've quoted before on this channel that
it may be difficult to know what role
money will play in a post AGI world all
that seems out of the window though and
there's only one thing they're promising
open ai's nonprofit which does still
exist they say will continue to exist
and Thrive and receive full value for
its current stake we don't know the
exact figure but I think their current
stake is in the region of 30% of the
current value of open AI in other words
that nonprofit will be bunged 50 maybe
$80 billion and receive quote full value
yes that will surely give it an enhanced
ability to pursue its Mission but that's
not the same as Microsoft not owning AGI
that's the same Microsoft by the way
that was reported just today in the
information was boasting about how much
labor cost you could save if you adopt
AI they're being explicit about making
sales for their co-pilot service based
on showing the examp example to their
customers of how they laid off 10,000
people last year that's according to
three current sales employees we've been
able to improve our throughput per
customer service agent by 12% using
co-pilot that's real money that means we
don't have to hire as many people
Microsoft SPO said is that the kind of
company that you want controlling AGI oh
and by the way I haven't even got to the
third thing that open AI are potentially
trying to distract us from they have
pivoted to work inside the military
industrial complex albeit with some
small caveat as MIT reports at the start
of this year opening eyes rules for how
Armed Forces might use its technology
were unambiguous no one could use their
models for weapons development or
military or Warfare then that changed in
January to don't use our technology to
harm yourself or others by developing or
using weapons or destroying property
that destroying property went out of the
window quite quickly in October they
changed the terms to you can only use it
to protect people and deter adversaries
now though their technology will be
deployed directly on the battlefield to
help apparently the US and Allied Forces
defend against drone attacks now you can
argue the Rights and Wrongs of this but
you've got to admit it's a shift in
policy as one analyst said defensive
weapons are indeed still weapons they
can often be positioned offensively
subject to the local and aim of a
mission open AI MIT says has long
pontificated about how to Steward AI
responsibly and they will now work in a
defense tech industry that plays by an
entirely different set of rules in that
system when your customer is the US
military tech companies do not get to
decide how their products are used and
according to the Washington Post even
their own employees are pushing back on
the deal and asking for more
transparency from leaders wherever we
heard that before those openai employees
apparently want assurances that their
technology won't be directed against
human pilot aircraft it's a great point
right because a defensive weapon could
still be used against humans if those
humans are piloting offensive aircraft
one other open AI employee said that
defensive use cases still represented
militarization of AI and noted that the
fictional AI system Skynet which turns
on Humanity in The Terminator movies was
also originally designed to defend
against aerial attacks on North America
open aai Executives quickly acknowledge
the concerns it should immediately be
pointed out that they are not the only
ones with people like anthropic and meta
changing their policies to allow
military use of their technology if you
were looking for a purely positive
review of Sora I am sorry to have
disappointed you the videos can be
amazing if you ignore the physics and
the user interface is exemplary but it's
quite pricey for the number of credits
you get and I just wonder if these 12
days of releases might be distracting us
a little bit from other news about open
AI as always though let let me know what
you think thank you so much for watching
to the end and have a wonderful day